and speaking of Ukraine the White House
is finally fessing up about the cost so
far of this proxy war that we're funding
in Ukraine according to documents
obtained by Fox News digital the total
for now at least is
$11.2 billion with plans to spend
another 9.8 billion in the coming months
now to give you a sense of the enormity
of this our entire Pentagon budget is
about $800 billion so it's an eighth of
what we spend for our country and to
think Congress wouldn't give Trump am
easly five billion for the wall joining
me now is Ohio Senator JD Vance who had
been demanding this information for the
B Administration for months Senator um
the OM director sent you a letter saying
this funding is critical to Ukraine's
success on the
battlefield uh what is their definition
of success these days over there Senator
that's precisely the problem Laura is
the president refuses to define success
and refuses to actually tell us how much
money we have to spend and how much time
we have to spend to get to that success
this is a classic military Quagmire this
is what we've been told for Generations
that we have to avoid a blank check that
is unlimited that sends money out the
door without any obvious benefit to our
national interest my very basic question
of Republicans and Democrats alike is
why are we being such a cheap date of
the Biden Administration if they're
asking for another 9 billion another
another 24 billion you know what's
another 35 billion among friends why
don't we at the very least demand to
know what that money is going to buy and
how it gets us closer to Victory um
Anthony blinkin the Secretary of State
wants everyone to know why we need to
keep spending this money and this is
what he
said I think it's very clear to us uh
and to to many uh in Congress that this
additional assistance is something that
Ukraine needs In This Moment it's not
only the right thing to do it's the
smart uh and necessary thing to do in
our own
interests in our own interests well the
American people don't think so and
certainly it looks like a majority of
Republicans an do not think so so that
means Senate leadership is not
representing the desires and concerns
and the priorities of their own
constituents absolutely right Laura and
you hear this slogan again and again
it's not just the right thing to do but
it's in our own interest but they never
Define how it's in our own interests and
here's what this war is costing us
potentially a worldwide food crisis
because Ukraine is the Bread Basket of
Europe God forbid a potential nuclear
war if this thing escalates further
Europe already has an energy crisis
where destabilizing izing Allied
governments in Eastern Europe because
they can't afford food or fuel for their
citizens so we're not just sending $150
billion we're actually causing
significant problems for ourselves it is
not in our interest to continue to fund
this indefinitely well did the North
Korean dictator now make you know um
overtures to Putin and the two of them
are going to get even closer not that
they were total enemies before but
they're going to be working together
more Russia's getting closer to China
closer to North Korea and oh by the way
Laura you have to remember we don't make
enough of our own artillery shells our
own Munitions to actually fund God
forbid a future military conflict if it
ever came with China so we're actually
firing bullets in Russia and in Ukraine
that we need for ourselves this is a
massive depletion of our own military
resources L you can go down the list and
identify the ways in which this is a
direct contravention of our national
interest the idea that it serves
America's national interest I think is
just a farce um I was reading something
online forgive me for not remembering
the source but it was a former military
official high ranking who said that if
we were to take on China if we wanted to
take on China if they went into Taiwan
if this if that would come about we
would need a national draft a military
draft because of the massive deficits we
have in recruiting who who there on
Capitol Hill is going to be now going to
the American people say by the way
everyone get ready to sit by your radio
or TV or go online because your draft
number might be called up it's exactly
right especially when we don't even
manufacture enough weapons to give those
troops troops even if we did draft them
this is a huge huge catastrophe Laura
and and think about this why does China
want the war between Russia and Ukraine
to continue indefinitely why do they
want America to continue to feed
billions of dollars into UK why want in
Iraq and Afghanistan they love that too
because it distracts us from the real
threat which is the Chinese this is a
massive massive strategic victory for
China because every minute that we focus
on Russia is a minute that we're not
focused on China Senator thanks for
coming into the studio great to see you
and he's wearing jeans with his Blazer
by the way sorry I had to just out you
on that hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else